hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in [ __ ] McCain a
Facebook nine Aristotle is bringing up
the topic that we see talked about quite
a bit in our own time and it can be done
to kind of a trivial way and I'll sort
of like what talk shows do but it
actually has some very deep and
important routes and it's whether a
person can be friends or feel affection
towards themselves and why is this so
important well Aristotle tells us ance
of a points in Nick o mckay ethics book
9 something about a friendship that was
left out earlier in book 8 and that is
that the way in which we are friends
with other people is based in part on
our own feelings towards herself so you
know when pop psychologists tell us you
know in the present that you can't love
others without loving yourself there's
actually something there from an
Aristotelian point of view but it's not
just about well you want to that emit
therefore love yourself you need to have
a basis on which you could actually find
yourself lovable so there's a little bit
of a difference in emphasis between
today's you know pop psychologists and
an Aristotelian moral theorists so the
way that Aristotle approaches this
question in n book 9
is to ask us about certain core features
of freshen and he provided a number of
those in book eight and he you know
re-emphasizes some of those in book nine
but then also adds a few to the list
that are very interesting so let's look
at this list first and then we'll see
whether it can apply to the good person
and to the bad person because that's
where the key dividing line is going to
be so a friend as Aristotle says wishes
good and also here he says promotes the
good whether it's the real or apparent
good of the other the other person for
the sake of that friend that is they
they want the other person to be doing
well but now of course you know in
friendship that's based on utility or
pleasure it's not because you love the
friend in themselves you know who they
are their personality in the corum who
they are your life narrative it's rather
than you know they're useful for you are
pleasurable for you but you still want
that to be you still want things to be
well for them at least it so you can get
something out of it now there's another
addition to this that looks very similar
he says the friend wishes existence and
preservation of the friend for the
friends sake so this is living or this
is living well doing well this is living
and existing literally you know being a
tack in Greek and so the friend wants
the friend to remain in existence have
to be saved and preserved you know
things not to go fall apart for them
right they don't want their friends to
get sick I don't want their friends to
have an accident or anything like that
where is what you get the idea with
Aristotle if it happens to strangers we
might feel such a pity but what happened
really that concerned another key
element that was talked about a lot in
can book eight friends actually spend
time together generally doing some sort
of activities or engaging in some sort
enjoyment with each other yeah this
Aristotle really takes to be at the core
of friendship if you remember a bookie
he says if people feel you know
affection towards each other but they
don't actually spend time together
they're not really friends in a full
sense there has to be that condition of
spending time friends designer and
choose the same things the emphasis
really here is on choice they you might
say they commit to they have the same
sorts of priorities they are the same
sorts of values it may not be exactly
the same across the board but they do
you know come together and we see this
indeed in make cases of friendship where
you thought that you are on the same
page with the person that it turns out
that you're not you don't really share
the same values and choices you know
there there's a lot of ways in which
this would come up sometimes in crises
sometimes over the period of time
friends have to sometimes decide to
choose the same thing as each other and
then finally this is one that that's
quite unique to this this section but it
makes perfect sense within Aristotle's
framework he says friends share joys and
sorrows they share pains and pleasures
but they also share joys and sorrows
these these these emotions so those are
key aspects to friendship and now the
question that Aristotle is going to ask
is how does this play out for the good
person and how does this play off of the
bad person let's take a look at the good
person first he says the good person do
they wish and promote the good of the
friend for the sake of the friend is the
friend is indeed themselves and he says
yes they wish their own good real as
well as appearance and they seek it by
action for it's a mark of the good man
to exert himself actively for the good
and he does so for his own sake where he
does it on account of the better part
of himself the intellectual part of
himself and this appears to be what a
person is at their poor man says
person's real self so a good person
certainly does that what about that is
the second part of wishing existence he
says he desires his own life and
security especially they'll just
rational part so that person is going to
take pains to preserve their rational
part they're not going to just sit
around and vegetate all day long
watching shows on Netflix or getting
themselves involved in activities that
are just you know without any sort of
intellectual value right that would not
be to be a friend with with yourself
well you know oftentimes you think well
you got to take care of yourself gana
you know pamper yourself maybe not so
much maybe maybe a true friend only does
that to a certain extent what about the
third one spending time together he says
the good person desires their own
company they enjoy being by himself
since they had agreeable memories of the
past good hopes of the future which are
pleasant to and also their mind is
stored with subjects for contemplation
people who can't stand being by
themselves and you can be by yourself in
our technological society in ways that
aren't really being by yourself if you
if you're always on the next if you're
just you know watching TV if you're
playing games that's it was certainly
beating by yourself but you're getting
lots and lots of stimulus being provided
by other people to you you know so it's
not exactly being by yourself the good
person can actually be by themselves in
a room without an awful lot of stuff and
they won't get bored because they have
plenty of things to think about to
consider they may even see it as a
little bit of a vacation from the cares
and worries that they normally have bit
of free time right different designer
and choose the same things with respect
to the individual
and he says well of course you know the
good person is of one mind with him or
herself and desire is the same things
with every part of their nature so this
is quite an important aspect in order to
be a good person for Aristotle you need
if not to be virtuous to be at least
self-control right and that means to be
able to choose to put things off put the
parts of yourself the desire is part of
the intellectual part into alignment
with each other so that you actually do
choose the same thing and you're not
torn by all these internal conflicts and
so the good person does actually do that
finally sharing joys and sorrows this is
quite an interesting one to consider
irritable suggests that the good person
is is he says keenly conscious of his
own joys and sorrows for the same things
give him pleasure or pain at all times
and not different things at different
times since he's not after to change his
mind there's a constancy in affection to
the good person that is going to be
lacking in in other people and because
of that he or she when they take joy in
something they're not going to take joy
in it one day and then be upset by it
the next day likewise what they find
upsetting one day if it truly is
upsetting they're going to find
upsetting the the next day has as well
so now let's consider does this apply do
these things apply to the bad person and
Aristotle says no the bad person that is
actually not going to be well off with
respect to this he says for example with
respect to the first thing the front
wishes and promotes the good of the
other for the sacred friend-friend
promotes the person's friends of
themself promotes their own good for
their own sake he's as bad people don't
do that they appear to be doing that but
they actually choose things that are bad
for them and so they're not really
promoting their own good he says I've
cowardness an island some they'd like to
do what they think for their own best
for their own interests so if you have
certain vicious dispositions you will go
against your own best interests and
you're not being a friend to yourself
and as a result he also says with
respect to this one which has to do with
life itself people who have committed a
number of crimes that are heated for
their wickedness actually flee from life
and make away with themselves so some
people can get to the point where they
they don't want to preserve their own
life because they find the person who
they are not just a life that they're
living but the person who they are to be
something that they don't want to exist
anymore you know in Aristotelian terms
this is really self-hatred when you hate
somebody as opposed to merely dis
lighting them or being angry with them
you you literally wish that they not
exist or that what they are not be what
it is spending time together this is
really interesting he said as bad people
constantly seek the Society of others he
has shunned their own company because
when they're by themselves what happens
they recall much that was unpleasant in
the past and anticipate anticipate the
same in the future whereas with other
people they can forget and he says they
also feel no affection for themselves
they don't want to spend time with
themselves because they have no lovable
qualities they don't have anything to
you know to offer to say hey this is
really good I want to be with somebody
like this they don't know they literally
can't hang out with themselves so what
they do is they try to find ways of not
paying attention to who they are they
had in fact sica of people who give them
a different self image right who flatter
them
example or who you know give them the
things that they can use to distract
themselves friends desire issues the
same things Aristotle said that's one of
the marks of the bad person they don't
remain constant over time in what they
choose there's kind of an internal
incoherence to moral badness it can't
always be on the same page with itself
and so Aristotle says that they lack
this finally sharing joys and sorrows
due to bad people at least do that so
it's no they don't enter into their own
joys and sorrows there's civil war in
their souls one part of their nature or
waiting to depravity is pained by
abstinence from certain indulgence while
another part is pleased by it one part
pulls them this way another part pulls
them another way as if pulling them
apart so he says if it's impossible to
feel plate pain and pleasure at the same
time at all events after indulging and
pleasure they regret it a little later
and wish they never acquired a taste for
such indulgences since the bad are
frequently changing their their minds so
they're not able to really enjoy their
joys to sort of mull them over and they
flee from their sorrows as well they
don't share in that and so they may be
looking for that in somebody else
external e but like we said you know if
you can't be a good friend to yourself
that makes it much more difficult to be
a good friend to another and you have
anything to offer to another person who
then might actually supply you with some
of these things on their own part so not
only by not being a friend with oneself
when the basis for head is not being a
good person does one preclude these from
oneself derived from oneself it's also
hard to have these to offer to another
person so that there could be some sort
of reciprocal exchange in friendship
with these